let's see if we can remove the parameter
T from a slightly more interesting
example so let's say that X is equal to
three times the cosine of T and Y is
equal to two times the sine of T we can
try to remove the parameter the same way
we did in the previous video where we
can solve for T in terms of either X or
Y and then substitute back in and we'll
do that I'll do that but I want to do
that first just to show you that it kind
of leads to a hairy or an unintuitive
answer so if we solve for
let's solve for T here and we can do it
either one they're equally complex so if
we will solve for T here we would say
divide both sides by two you would get Y
over two is equal to sine of T and then
you would take the arc sine of both
sides or the inverse sine of both sides
and you would get I like writing arc
sine because inverse sine off off people
often confuse it with an exponent taking
it to the negative one power
so arc sine of Y over two is equal to T
now actually let me do that little aside
there I should probably do it at the
trigonometry playlist but it's it's a
good thing to hit home because I think
people get confused sine so arc sine arc
sine of anything of let's say Y this is
the other way of writing that is sine
minus 1 of Y these two things are
equivalent when they're normally used
but I don't like using this notation
most of the time because it can be
ambiguous
this could mean sine of Y to the
negative one power this could mean sine
of Y to the negative one power which
equals one over sine of Y and arc sine
and this are definitely not the same
thing so you want to be very careful
there to make sure that you don't get
confused when someone writes an inverse
sine like this that they're not actually
taking sine of Y to the negative one
power on the other hand if someone were
to write sine squared of Y this is
unambiguously the same
thing as sine of Y squared in fact I
wish this was the more conventional
notation because it wouldn't make people
think of two and minus one there and and
of course that's just sine of Y squared
so it can be very ambiguous and of
course if this was a negative and this
would be a minus two and then this
really would be one over sine of Y
squared so I just that's why just a
long-winded way of explaining why I
wrote arc sine instead of sine inverse
sine right there
needless to say let's get back to the
problem so we've solved for T in terms
of Y now we can substitute back here and
we get an expression for X in terms of Y
so we get X is equal to three times the
cosine of T we just solve for T T is
this thing right here so it's the cosine
of arc sine arc sine of Y over 2 and we
have eliminated the parameter but this
is a very non-intuitive equation we
could have done the other way we could
have solved for Y in terms of X and
we've gotten you know the sine of the
arc cosine it would have been equally
hairy or not intuitive but in either way
we did remove the parameter so I guess
we could mildly pat ourselves on the
back but that's not the purpose of this
video the purpose of this video is to
see if there's any way we can remove the
parameter that leads to a more intuitive
equation involving X and y and what
we're going to do is I guess you can
call it a bit of a trick but it's
something that shows up a lot especially
when you deal with polar coordinates and
you might want to watch my polar
coordinate videos because this is
essentially touches on that but if I
said let me rewrite them X is equal to 3
cosine of T and Y is equal to 2 sine of
T so what we can do is just you know
think about well how can we write this
and you know close sine of T and sine of
T how can we relate them and the first
thing that comes to my mind is just the
unit circle or or to some degree the
most basic of all of the trigonometric
identities and that is that the cosine
squared of T plus the sine squared of T
is equal to 1 this comes from the unit
circle I explained it in the
it's circle video and that's because the
equation for the unit circle is x
squared plus y squared is equal to one
the cosine of the angle is the
x-coordinate the sine of the angle is
the y-coordinate so on and so forth but
this is our trig identity you don't have
to think about it too much right now
just I guess know that it's true and
watch some of the other videos if you
want to proven that it's true but if we
can somehow replace this cosine squared
with some expression in X and replace
the signs sine or the sine squared with
some expression Y we'd be done right and
then we would have it equaling one and
that shouldn't be too hard we can
rewrite this we can set cosine of t
equal to something in X and we can set
sine of T equal in something and Y and
so let's do that so we divide both sides
of this equation by 3 you get x over 3
is equal to cosine of t and if you
divide both sides of this equation by 2
you get Y over 2 is equal to sine of T
and then we can use this trigonometric
equate identity we can just instead of
the cosine of T we can substitute x over
3 instead of the sine of T we can
substitute Y over 2 and you get you get
x over 3 squared that's that right there
that's just cosine of T squared plus y
over 2 squared that's just sine of T
squared is equal to 1 and now this is
starting to look a lot better than this
this I have no idea what this is but
hopefully if you've watched the conic
section videos you can already recognize
that this is starting to look like an
ellipse we could simplify it a little
bit we could say this is equal to x
squared over 9 plus y squared over 4 is
equal to 1 and if we were to graph this
ellipse and we will actually graph it we
get let me draw my axes I'm using this
blue color a little bit too much getting
it's getting monotonous ok let me use a
purple so that's our x-axis that's our
y-axis
the major axis is in the X direction
because the denominator here is larger
than that one and it's the semi the the
semi major radius is going to be the
square root of this so it's 3 1 2 3 in
that direction 1 2 3 I know I'm centered
at 0 because neither of these are
shifted you should watch the conic
section videos if this sounds unfamiliar
to you and the semi-minor radius is the
square root of 4 so that's 2 so we get
1/2 and 1/2 let me see if I can draw
this ellipse so it would look something
like something like that there you go so
just like that by eliminating the
parameter T we got this equation in a
form that we immediately were able to
recognize as a lift when I just look at
that unless you deal with parametric
equations or maybe polar coordinates a
lot it's not obvious that this is the
parametric equation for an ellipse but
this once you learn about conic sections
it's pretty clear it's an ellipse and
it's easy to draw that ellipse but in in
in removing the T and from going from
these equations up here and from going
from that to that like in the last video
we lost information we lost 1 what is
the direction that we move in as T
increases and we also don't know what
point on this ellipse we are at any
given time T so to do that let's make
our little table let's make our little
table so let's take some values of T so
we'll make a little table T X and Y and
it's good to pick values of T remember
let me rewrite the equations again so we
didn't lose it X was equal to three
cosine of T and Y it was equal to two
sine of T it's going to take values of T
that it's easy where it's easy to figure
out what the cosine and sine are and
without using a calculator we're
assuming the T is in radians just for
simplicity so let's pick T is equal to 0
T is equal to PI over 2 that's 90
degrees and degrees and T is equal to PI
and so what is X when T is equal to zero
well cosine of zero is one times three
that's three what's X when T is you have
PI over two cosine of PI over 2 is 0 0
times 3 is 0 and what's X equal when T
is equal to PI cosine of PI is minus one
minus one times three is minus three
fair enough now let's do the Y's when T
is 0 what is y sine of zero is zero so 2
times zero is zero when T is PI over 2
sine of PI over 2 is 1 1 times 2 is 2
and when T is PI sine of PI that's sine
of 180 degrees that's zeros two times
zero is zero so let's plot these points
when time is zero we're at the point 3
comma 0 so 3 comma 0 3 comma 0 is right
there this is T equals 0 when T
increases by PI over 2 or if this was
seconds PI over 2 seconds it's like 1.7
something seconds so at T equals PI over
2 where the point zero comma two we're
at zero comma 2 we're right over here so
this is at T is equal to PI over 2 and
then when T increases a little bit more
when T's increased a little bit more
when we're at T is equal to PI we're at
the point minus three zero so minus 3 0
we're here so this is T is equal to PI
or you know we could write 3.14159
seconds
3.14 seconds and it actually you know I
don't want I want to make the point T
does not have to be time and we don't
have to be dealing with seconds but I
like to think about it that way I like
to think about you know maybe this is
describing some object in orbit around I
don't know something else so now we know
the direction as T increased from 0 to
PI over 2 to PI we went this way we went
counterclockwise so the direction of
these parametric equations is in that
direction and you might be saying Sal
you know why did we just why'd we have
to do 3 points we could have just done 2
and made a line if we just had that
point in that point you might have
immediately said oh we went from there
to there but that really wouldn't have
been enough because maybe we got from
here to there by going the other way
around so giving that Third Point lets
us know that the direction is definitely
counterclockwise and so what happens if
we just you know take T from 0 to
infinity right what happens if if we
bound TT is greater than 0 and less than
infinity well we're just going to keep
going around this ellipse forever
multiple times keep writing over and
over to infinite times if we went from
if we went from minus infinity to
infinity then we would have always been
doing it I guess is the way to put it or
if we just wanted to trace this out once
we could go from T is less than or equal
to or T is greater than or equal to zero
all the way to T is less than or equal
to 2 pi and in this situation t really
is the angle that we're tracing out if
we were to think of this in polar
coordinates this is T at any given time
and I just thought I would throw that
out there it isn't always but in this
case it really is so when you do when
you go from 0 to 2 pi radians you've
made one circle but this is about
parametric equations and not
trigonometry so I don't want to focus
too much on that but anyway that was
neat by we started with this if I just
showed you those parametric equations
you would have no idea what that looks
like but by recognizing the trig
identity we were able to simplify it to
an ellipse draw the ellipse and then by
plotting a couple of points we were able
to figure out the direction at which if
this was describing a particle in motion
the direction in which that particle
is actually moving anyway hope you
enjoyed that